Well, good morning church.
It is really good to see you all this morning,
especially you students.
I hope you all survived the weekend. Are we awake?
You guys with me? That was really,
there might be some sleeping here this morning.
We'll see. Well, I, if you haven't, if I haven't met you
yet, my name is Chris Cross.
I'm one of the elders here.
It's my privilege to serve you in that way
and I'm excited to get back into our study
of First Samuel this morning.
As much as I pushed for a Song of Solomon Study
to celebrate Valentine's Day,
this is probably the better option this morning.
But before we get into First Samuel,
let's start with a little story.
So back in 1946, there were two gentlemen, one by the name
of a Bookman and the other Albert C. Carter,
and they introduced the world to this little device
that if you shook it up, it would give you a
randomly generated answer.
Well, a couple of years later, in 1950,
a company called Brunswick Billiards commissioned these men
to take that toy
and repackage it into a promotional
product that they could use.
And that's when it became known as the Magic eight Ball.
Now this is the knockoff version that you can get
for like 800 tickets at Main Event if you wanna make a trip
over after church.
Uh, but I'm sure most of us had one of these little vices,
or at least knew someone that did as a kid.
And we used to ask some of our most deepest,
profound life questions of these little things.
Questions like, does Jimmy have a crush on Marisa?
And if you were like my sister,
maybe you were asking questions like, will I get
to marry Jonathan Taylor Thomas?
Or perhaps you have questions like me?
Questions like, is this the year
that the Dallas Cowboys finally win a Super Bowl?
Yeah, yeah. You guys right?
The answer is always wouldn't bet on it, right?
Well, as we grow up, we stop using these little devices
to answer our questions, but wouldn't it be nice if we had
something like this that we could call on, right?
To answer those questions that we have now, questions like,
should I take that job
or is this the right person for me to marry?
Or how about this one?
How about, uh, should I quit my job
and live overseas as a missionary live since, right?
Or how about should I forgive that family member who hurt me
and if I do, do I let them back into my life?
You see, we have these questions as humans,
because we are so limited in our knowledge,
we don't know what's around the corner,
we don't know what's gonna lead to the best outcomes.
And if I'm honest, I ask these questions
because I just wanna know what's gonna make me happiest
or at least the most comfortable in life.
Or perhaps we don't ask these questions at all
because we just assume we already know what's best
for our lives, and so we just act accordingly.
But in our better moments, I think we ask these questions
because we actually, we truly want to know
what God's will is.
You see, at least in our limited knowledge, we understand
that he is unlimited in his.
At least we understand that he does have a plan
and at least we understand that he is mindful of us.
Yet oftentimes I think we struggle with this question
of discerning what is God's will.
Now let me be perfectly clear.
I don't want you to be misled this morning.
God is not some magic eight ball that we just shake up
and peer into whenever we have a decision
that we need to make in life.
Now, what we'll see today is that God is actually
so much better than that
and the way that he works with us to reveal his will.
So as we continue in one Samuel this morning, we will see
through the life of David
that God does reveal his will to his people.
The question then becomes are we a people
who inquire of him?
Are we a people who listen
and obey to the will that he does reveal to us?
So to see how that plays out in David's story,
let us turn now to God's revealed words.
So please turn with me in your Bibles
to First Samuel chapter 23.
And as you make your way there, let's go before the Lord
and let's seek him out in prayer
because we do need him this morning.
So Father, we come before you this morning
and we open up our hearts to you.
God give us ears that hear your word, give us hearts
that are submitted to your will.
Speak to us through your living
and active word this morning.
We trust what you promise is true, that you will speak
to us if we seek you, Lord.
So speak to us this morning, submit our hearts to you.
It's in your name we pray. Amen.
So starting in chapter 23, verse one says,
now they told David,
behold the Philistines are fighting against keila
and are robbing the threshing floors.
So let's, let's stop there.
Before we get too far into this story,
let's get our bearings with where we are,
where we're at in First Samuel.
Remember first Samuel is a narrative.
So it's important that we look at each individual story in
the context of the,
of the greater plot that's being told here.
So how did we get here?
Well, if you recall over the last few chapters, we know
that David is on the run from King Saul.
So Saul was God's first appointed king of Israel,
yet he has been rejected by God
because of this pattern of blatant disobedience
that he continues to have against God's will.
And we learned in chapter 16 that God has appointed David
described as a man
after God's own heart to succeed King Saul as the next
uh, heir to the throne.
And as God has brought success
after success to David, David's popularity
amongst the people of Israel has continued to increase.
But along with that,
Saul's jealousy has also continued to increase.
And we see King Saul refusing to accept God's will for him
and the kingdom, and he becomes obsessed with killing David
and eliminating him from the picture.
You see, Saul appears to believe that he has the power
to force his own will
and becoming reality in spite of what God has clearly
told to him, clearly revealed to him that there was
to be another that was going to inherit the throne.
So over the last couple of weeks, we have seen Saul's
continue spiral into this self obsession that has led him
to completely distort his perception of reality.
And this is what we saw last week when he came to Knob
and massacred the city of Knob.
And along with it, 85 priests of the Lord and the women
and the children, all Israelites, all his own people,
he massacres there except for there's one priest
that escapes Knob Abiathar and he flees to David
and we'll see him show up today in our story.
So with that, that all brings us to chapter 23.
And with that context, let's start back again in verse one.
Now they told David,
behold the Philistines are fighting against keah
and are robbing the threshing floors.
Therefore, David inquired of the Lord, shall I go
and attack these Philistines?
And the Lord said to David, go and attack the Philistines
and save keah.
But David's man said to him, behold,
we are afraid here in Judah how much more than if we go
to Keah against the armies of the Philistines.
Then David inquired of the Lord again,
and the Lord answered him, arise, go down to Keah
for I will give the Philistines into your hand.
And David and his men went tequila
and fought with the Philistines
and brought away their livestock
and struck them with a great blow.
So David saved the inhabitants of Kela.
So the last time that we saw David, he
and his men were hiding out in the forest
of Herath and Judah.
Now how did they get there?
Well, if you remember back in chapter 22,
the prophet Gad had instructed David to get out
of the strongholds in which they were hiding
and go into the land of Judah.
Now, on the surface, this does not seem like the most
strategic move, move for David to do because he,
after all, he's trying to hide from Saul, right?
So why would he want to go to Judah?
Where, where Saul
and all of his allies would be crawling all over
that land looking for David know the most strategic thing
that David could have done, the safest thing to do,
the most reasonable thing to do would've been
to stay in the strongholds away from kings Saul
where he could not find them.
But nevertheless, David is there in the strongholds waiting
for God to tell him what to do next.
You see, God has been conditioning David to be still enough
to listen to his will.
And this is quite the change from the fear-driven antics
that we saw in David early on in his flight from Saul,
that was the David that we saw deceive a alek, the priest
to get provisions from him.
That was the David that we saw pretending to be a mad man,
pretending to be crazy, to get away from the Philistines
and Gath right now, you see David has quieted,
or sorry, God has quieted David's heart
and refocused David's attention
and turned his ear back towards him to listen.
And David says so himself in thinking about these events,
he writes in Psalm 56, he says this, I know that God is
for me and God whose word I praise in the Lord whose word I
praise and God I trust
I shall not be afraid.
What can man do to me?
See, David's trust now is in whatever God has for him
wherever God wants him to go, no matter how sensible
or nons sensible it might seem, he is quiet now
and he is settled even in the middle of this storm
that he finds himself in.
Because even in the middle of that storm, David is confident
that he is carried along by the one who shows the wind how
to blow and tells the rain where to fall.
So when God tells him through the prophet Gad, get up,
get out of the strongholds
and go into the land of Judah, he doesn't hesitate.
He doesn't need to know why.
He just gets up and he goes,
and then he waits there in Judah for
what the Lord will do next and what the Lord does next
and bring him word from Keah
that the Philistines are oppressing the Israelites there.
And here we see David's dilemma.
So Keila was a fortified city
in Judah about 20 miles to the south and west of Jerusalem.
And we hear here that David gets word
that the Philistines are pressing the Israelites there
by robbing the threshing floors.
The, so the threshing floors would've been these areas
outside of the city walls
where the Israelite farmers would've been bringing in their
grain to be stamped out and processed into food.
So when the Philistines are coming
and oppressing the Israelite farmers there,
they're robbing them of the fruits of their labor.
But not only that, they're cutting off supply lines,
food supply for the city of Kila.
And so you can see this is a pretty desperate situation
that Keah finds itself in.
And so they put out this call for help
and the call comes to David as he's in the forest of Herath.
Now, it's interesting that this call comes to David.
Why not Saul? Saul's the king.
Saul's the one that God tells in chapter nine
to save the Israelite people from the
hand of the Philistines.
Isn't this Saul's responsibility to come to the rescue
of Keah or perhaps the call does come to Saul
and he just ignores it?
Perhaps Saul is too busy with his conquest
to hunt down David and kill David,
that he completely ignores his responsibility
to his own people and doesn't come to Keah.
Now, we don't know for certain why Saul isn't in Keah
or why Saul didn't come,
but we do know that the call goes out to David for help.
And so what does David do here?
He is hiding out for his life in Judah,
and yet he is faced with this decision
because his neighbors over here need help.
They find themselves in a crisis.
So stop and think for a second.
What would you do in this moment? Or what would I do?
On the one hand, we might be tempted to think, well man,
I've got enough on my plate as it is.
I've got Saul breathing down my neck,
I've got his spies crawling all over
the land looking for me.
I've got these 400 men here who are all looking to me
to give them guidance to help them, to protect them,
to lead them in right ways.
Now, I understand this, there's a problem here,
but surely this isn't my responsibility at the time.
Or perhaps we'd be on the other side of that coin
and we would hear of this crisis, someone in need of help,
and we would just jump right in
and say, well man, I can fix that.
Come on guys, let's go. Let's go take care of this situation
and jump right in.
Might suggest that actually both
of those responses would be wrong.
Instead, let's look at what David does here.
You'll see it in verse two.
It says, therefore David inquired of the Lord,
shall I go and attack these Philistines?
And the Lord said to David, go and attack the Philistines
and save keah.
You see, before taking any action, David wanted to know
what God's will was.
So we brought it before him.
And this is the first principle that I want us
to learn this morning, that if we really want to know
what God's will is,
and I know I have all of you, you hanging on the edge
of your seats because we all wanna
know what God's will is, right?
But listen, if we really wanna know what God's will is,
we should seek him.
Now you're probably thinking, well, gee, Chris, thank you,
captain obvious, right?
Yeah, captain obvious. But listen, think about this.
I think there's oftentimes that we think we want
to know what God's will is.
Or we say we wanna know what God's will is,
but we don't actually ask him.
We don't actually seek him.
We don't look for what he's revealed His will already to be,
or perhaps we do ask him, but it's only
after we've already decided for ourselves what, what he,
what we want his will to be.
And trust me, we are awfully good at convincing ourselves
that God's will aligns with our own if we're not careful.
In fact, we're gonna see an example of
that played out in just a few verses ahead.
But this isn't what David does.
He is presented with information,
this opportunity to make a decision.
And before he does anything else, he brings it
before the Lord and says, God, what would you have me do?
Shall I go down? Shall I save keah?
Now, it doesn't tell us exactly
how David inquires of the Lord here.
Perhaps it was through the prophet Gad
who we assume is still with him,
or perhaps it was directly in prayer.
We don't really know. But what we do know is that God
clearly tells him, yes, go and save Keah.
But remember David isn't alone here.
He's got this ragtag army of 400 misfit men that are
with him, and they're not so convinced about
where David says God is leading them.
See that in verse three, they come against him
and say, behold, we are afraid here in Judah
how much more than if we go to keah against the armies
of the Philistines?
And their response really isn't all that surprising, right?
I mean, we can understand the position that they're in to go
to Keah, to fight against the Philistines would've been
putting them in danger enough as it is.
But even more so than that, by going there,
they would be outing themselves to Saul, the one
that they've been hiding from,
and he would know exactly where they were.
And you know this, this reminds me
that there are many times when God has clearly given his
will to us and it doesn't make sense to others,
especially sometimes those that are closest to us.
And we are often faced with opposition that tells us, well,
that doesn't really seem wise
or That's not what I would do, but get this.
Isn't that so true of God's clearly expressed
will in his word?
Sometimes it doesn't often make sense, at least to
what makes sense to to humanity, right to us.
Yet we see Jesus tell us things like love your
enemies what?
Pray for those who persecute you. Or what about this one?
If someone sues you
and takes your shirt, well just give him your coat.
Also are are you serious Jesus? Like, think about that.
Yet, God's ways, his will are
so much better than our ways.
His definition of wisdom is so much better,
so much higher than ours.
So David here, he hears the concerns of his men,
valid concerns in the human sense.
And what does he do? Does he counter back?
Does he just ignore them?
Does he give in to the majority opinion
and not go down to keah?
No. What does he do? Tells us in verse four that again,
he inquires of the Lord.
And then it says, the Lord answered him, arise, go down
to keah for I will give the Philistines into your hand.
Now, isn't that beautiful?
Not only does God tell David what he want,
what he wants he and his men to do,
but he gives him this promise
that he will give him the victory over the Philistines.
And what if we look across all of scripture, we see time
and time and time again that God always
delivers on his promises.
And that's exactly what he does here.
See it in verse five, says in David and his men went to Kela
and fought with the Philistines
and brought away their livestock
and struck them with a great blow.
So David saved the inhabitants of Kela.
I mean, how great is that ending to this episode? Right?
David inquires of the Lord.
He waits and he listens for
what God will will instruct him to do.
And then he acts upon what God tells him to do and
because of his willingness to submit to God's will,
what a victory that God brings for his people.
This brings us to the second principle I want us
to learn this morning, that
to walk in God's will, we must seek him.
Yes, but then we must also be willing to listen
to his revealed truth as he gives it to us.
This is why we find that phrase He who has ears to hear,
let him hear written all over the scriptures
because God does reveal himself
and God does reveal his will to his people.
Now, we may not be privy to every part of God's will,
and we're absolutely not going to understand every part
of the will that he does reveal to us.
Paul himself wonders over this in Romans 11.
He says, oh, the depth of the riches and wisdom
and knowledge of God, how unsearchable are his ways?
How inscrutable
or how sorry, how unsearchable are his judgments?
How inscrutable his ways.
Yet God clearly has revealed much of his will to us
through his word written in the Bible
and through his word, lived out in the flesh in Jesus.
You see, the beginning of knowing God's will is to know him,
to know who he has revealed himself to be.
And we know this to be true, that to really know the will
of anyone, you must know that person the way
that they think, their patterns, their consistent character.
And I'll give you an example of that.
So there are two types of people when it comes
to getting back from a vacation.
On the one hand you have the type
that you been a long trip home, you're tired,
you bring all the bags in from the car, you go
to the laundry room and you just
drop 'em in the laundry room.
And then what do you do? You go to bed, right?
You wait to tackle that in the morning.
And then there's my beautiful wife, Mara.
See, we love to road trip as a family
to the beaches in Florida.
And on the last day of that trip,
we'll get up early like 5:00 AM we'll pack up the car
and we'll drive for the 16 hours all
the way back to Oklahoma.
It's late. We're tired.
And in that moment, what do you think my will is?
Oh, I'm ready. Yeah, I'm the first type.
I'm ready to go to bed. But
what do you think Mara's will is in that moment?
It does not matter how late it is
or how tired she is, she is not going to rest
until every sock
and toothbrush has been put back in its rightful place.
And even the luggage itself has been tucked away into bed
for sweet slumber.
And you see, even though
Mara's will is polar opposite from mine,
I'm able to know her will.
I'm able to understand it kind of,
and I'm able to step into it because I know her, I love her
and I want to honor her.
And to be honest, what I found out in marriage is her will
is usually better than mine is.
But so it is with knowing God's will we begin
by waking up to this fact that he has spoken his will
in many ways over millennia, over thousands of years,
he has revealed who he is to his people, how he thinks,
his patterns, his consistent character.
Hebrews one instructs us that long ago at many times,
and in many ways God spoke to our fathers by the prophets,
but in these days he has spoken to us by his son.
So the question then is, are we willing
to listen to his word?
Are we willing to listen
to his revealed will in the scriptures
and in the life of Jesus?
And are we then willing to step into
that will even when it's opposed to our own will?
And with that question that brings us now
to look at Saul's delusion.
So let's pick back up in first Samuel 23.
Starting back in verse six says, when a BFR, the son
of a Himalaya had fled to David tequila, he had come down
with an EOD in his hand.
Now we'll get back to that in a second.
Now, I was told Saul that David had come tequila
and Saul said, get this, God has given him into my hand
for he has shut himself in by entering a town
that has gates and bars.
And Saul summoned all the people to war to go down tequila
to besiege David and his men.
So let's stop there. Did you happen to notice the condition
of Saul's heart right here?
He is utterly delusional in his perception of reality.
He hears that David is in Kela
and David's there fighting against the Philistines
that he should be fighting against.
And yet somehow he thinks that God is giving David over
to him into his hand for Saul to kill him, to murder him.
I mean, we read stories like this
and we just wanna think like Saul, wake up man.
But let this remind us that we are all equally capable
of falling into such delusions if we're not rooted in
Christ, if we are not
after God's own heart.
Jeremiah 17, nine declares that the heart is deceitful
above all things and it is desperately sick
who can understand it?
We don't even understand our own hearts most of the time.
This is why it's imperative
that we take every thought captive
and that we test every motivation of our hearts.
This is why it's critical
that we pray prayers like David does in Psalm 1 39,
and we say, search me, oh God, know my heart.
Try me and know my thoughts Lord,
see if there'd be any grievous in way,
and then God lead me in the way of everlasting.
See, Saul's heart was so deceived by his selfish ambition
that he projected his own will onto Gods,
even though God had made it abundantly clear
that his will was for Saul to no longer be king.
Saul rejects God's will
and rather makes up this false reality
to support what he wants.
And notice the contrast that we see here
between Saul and David.
You see Saul when he's with presented
with information about Keah, what does he do?
He just assumes that he knows God's will
and then acts according to what he feels is best.
But when David is presented
with information about Keah, what does he do?
Yeah, we saw it twice. He inquires of the Lord.
See, while David was seeking
after the kingdom of God, Saul was seeking
after his own kingdom, Saul's kingdom.
So likewise, our third principle is this.
If we are to walk in God's will, we must be willing
to surrender our own kingdoms.
As we look to abide in his brothers
and sisters, let us be a people who seek first the kingdom
of God who submit to his lordship over our lives
and then who abide, who live in the peace of his provision
and his judgments.
So as we pick back up in verse nine, we'll continue to see
how how David's submission to God's kingdom
continues to play itself out.
So look with me at verse nine.
It says, David knew that Saul was plotting harm against him,
and he said to a BFR of the priest, bring the EOD here.
All right, so what is the deal with the eod?
We've seen it mentioned twice here now, right?
So the EO would've been this garment
that the high priest wore covering his torso
and attached to the EOD would've been
what was called the breast piece of judgment or decision.
And in that breast piece would've been contained
what was called the Uum and the tum.
So what were the Uum and the tum
besides some fun words to say, well,
we don't really know exactly.
Most scholars believe that these were probably two stones,
a white stone and a dark stone
that the priest would use in discerning god's will.
So basically it would look like this.
They would ask a question of the Lord, a yes
or no question, then they would reach into the breast piece
and pull out one of these two stones.
If it was a white one, the answer is yes.
If it's a black one, the answer is no.
Now, this might seem like the priests were just relying on
blind chance to discern God's will and make a decision.
But scripture tells us this is clearly one of the ways
that God had instructed his people at the time
to seek out God's will
and to listen to what he wanted them to do.
And think about this, the fact that God worked
through something as seemingly random
as this should only elevate our perspective
of God's sovereignty.
I mean, this blows my mind that everything, even
what seems like pure chance to us,
like basically flipping a coin
are within his complete divine knowledge and control.
Doesn't that blow your mind of how God can get his outcomes
of his will out of something like that?
And let this also be a comfort to you if you find yourself
paralyzed in trying to discern God's will
because you don't wanna mess up his plans.
Trust me, even if you wanted to, you don't have the power
to disrupt God's will.
There is nothing that you can do that can thwart God's plans
or upend his sovereign decree.
If it is God's will, it's going to happen period.
And if you need proof of this, just look at the empty tomb
because in man's best attempt to stop the reign
of Jesus and literally kill God's will,
they crucified him on a cross.
But Sunday came, didn't it?
And with it, the resurrection
and glorious display of Christ Jesus,
our Lord's sovereign victory over sin and death
and any force that could possibly stand in
his way of reigning.
So believe me, if he can overcome that, there is no decision
that you or I can make that will stand in his way
of doing what he wants.
So David calls on a BSR of the priest to bring the ephod
to him because he wants to seek out God's will
when he hears of Saul's threats.
And he cries out in verse 10, look with me there.
He says, oh Lord, the God of Israel,
your servant has surely heard that Saul seeks to come
to Keah to destroy the city on my account.
Will the men of keah surrender me into his hand?
Will Saul come down as your servant has heard, oh Lord,
the God of Israel, please tell your servant.
And the Lord said he will come down.
Then David said, will the men of keyless surrender me
and my men into the hand of Saul?
And the Lord said, they will surrender you.
Then David and his men who are about 600 arose
and departed from Keah and they went wherever they could go.
When Saul was told that David had escaped from Keah,
he gave up the expedition
and David remained in the strongholds and the wilderness
and the hill country of the wilderness of Ziff.
And Saul sought him every day,
but God did not give him into his hand.
I want us to notice here the posture of David
before Yahweh, the Lord, especially in comparison
to the arrogance that we just saw.
And Saul David three times here refers
to himself as God's servant taking on the posture
of submission to the one true king Yahweh,
the God of Israel.
So when hearing that Saul was coming down
to do battle against him, so David could have had any number
of knee-jerk reactions, he could have been fearful
and tried to convince the people of Keah to hide him
or protect him from Saul.
On the other hand, he could have been angry
or obstinate and decided, you know what?
No, I'm gonna stand my ground
and I'm not gonna, I'm gonna fight Saul
and I'm gonna, I'm going
to defeat him like I just did the Philistines.
But no, it is with a servant mindset that he again,
seeks out the Lord's guidance realizing
that it was ultimately God's kingdom
that was being established, not David's.
So God answers him
and reveals that Saul is indeed coming down.
And he also reveals that the people of Keah whom David
and his men had just saved by the way,
would indeed betray him
and hand him over to be killed by Saul if he were to stay.
Now, I don't wanna miss something really important here
that we see about God and his omniscience.
Did you catch this? There's this fact
that God even knows the outcome of potential scenarios
that never even come to pass.
He knows that the inhabitants
of Keah would have handed David over
to Saul if he were to have stayed.
I mean, how high above us is God's wisdom, his omniscience,
his sovereign knowledge over all things, all circumstances,
even those that don't ever happen.
And this is where we get to witness God's deliverance.
See, because God's word is trustworthy, David
and his men are delivered from Saul once
again by the hand of the Lord.
And I want us to notice something really important
here in this instance.
God doesn't tell David exactly what he should do next.
David seeks out wisdom from the Lord.
Yes, but God doesn't tell him what his next steps should be.
Instead he gives him insight, he gives him knowledge, yes.
But then he lets David act according
to his own judgment based on that information, based on
what God has revealed to him.
And as David trusts that God has for him
and remembers that God has proven
to deliver him from his enemies, he makes the decision
to not fight against Saul,
to not bring destruction on the city of Keah,
but instead to depend upon God for deliverance
as he escapes to the wilderness.
So here we see our final principle that I want us
to learn this morning, that to walk according to God's will,
we should follow David's example
and obey the will that God has revealed to us.
And then we should trust him fully with the outcome.
So what are we to do with this story?
So we, yes, we've looked at these four principles
that we should follow if we are to walk in God's will,
but I admit there is a temptation
for me when I read stories like this in the Bible
where God clearly speaks his will of direction to someone
that I begin to think, well,
why doesn't God show up in my life that way?
Perhaps if I just pray hard enough
or if I look for the right signs,
or if I interpret the stars right, then I'm gonna know
what God's will is for me.
And while I will say yes, God does work in
that way at times when he deems it necessary.
Let's not forget the central plot line
of which this story sits in one Samuel.
This whole account of of one Samuel
is about God bringing about his will to raise up David and
and establish him as the king of Israel.
Yes, for the good of pe of the good of the people
of Israel at the time, but ultimately
to establish the messianic line by which Jesus
would eventually come centuries later to inherit the throne.
So we shouldn't be surprised at all
to see God working in some pretty remarkable overt ways here
to make sure that that mission comes to pass, right?
So while we wish that we could have a priest
and an eod, a Euro and a humum,
or at bare minimum, a divine magic eight ball
to give us direction to our decisions
or our dilemmas, let me challenge you to believe
that those things were just shadows of the better access
that we have to God now, the better access that we have
to God's will today, you see,
because God did carry out his will for Jesus, the Messiah
to come through the line of David.
And because Jesus in perfect submission to the Father's,
will left heaven to come
and save a people who also would betray him,
we now have a great high priest in Jesus
who is seated at the right hand
of the majesty of throne in heaven.
And he's interceding on our behalf forever.
And by his spirit whom he sent, which indwells us,
we have now been given direct access to God who guides us
and leads us into all truth.
And finally, we have something that David didn't have.
We have the entirety of God's written word at our fingertips
and in it the beautiful treasure of God's redemptive plan
for humanity and who he is
and what he wants for us.
So believer, I'll leave you with this.
Inquire of the Lord, seek him
and His will listen
and obey to what He commands.
And then let's trust him as we wait
to see what he will do next.
And to that end, will you pray with me?
Father, we do seek you this morning,
Lord, we do admit that your will, your ways are
so much higher than ours.
God, give us hearts that are submitted to your kingdom.
God, we lay down our own kingdoms, our own wills,
our own selfish ambitions.
We lay it at the foot of the cross
and say, God, do with us what you will.
This people that you've purchased by your blood
for yourself, God, do with us what you will.
We're submitted to you. Reveal yourself to us
through your word, through your son Jesus.
And let us step into that will God.
We love you. We depend upon you,
and we wait for what you will do next.
So as we get ready to sing this next song,
I would encourage you just
to take a few more moments and sit there.
The worship team is gonna come back up
and we're gonna sing this song together, but sit there
and consider what it means to live within God's will.
Seek him out, inquire of him,
and then see what he will do as we wait for him.
Let's worship together as we wrap up this morning.